how's it going bro let's get some
freaking hype in the chat fro
cuz we are bringing back all the million
club merch
up until a hundred okay starting at 50
million ready now let's freakin get it
bro big description let's live wide time
leave your entry C&S already closed
now I may have sneak peaked a little bit
I'm sorry it happened one time and hit
everyone hates on morgues spoiler this
hole the Y will just be mr. B's and
morgues memes I don't know how this
happened I don't know how it started
but it's a thing 62,000 uploads morgues
so how did a video ders Arthur mope
that's how he talks in case you didn't
get the joke I'm in a bit of a pickle
he's out of video ideas don't worry I'm
about to start uploading more soon oh
damn oh is that real that sandwich I
gotta find out that's real is it real
look I don't follow anyone anymore so I
don't see people's tweets ah ha ha ha ok
so apparently the more times have been
copying his videos way back I didn't
know this is a thing I just briefly
touched on it in one video I'm like dude
is he just copying and I didn't look
into it but apparently it's the whole
thing it's like the whole new drama top
the excuse me no one cares about your
team Jon I'll teach you excuse me don't
get it's all about morgues vs. mr. B's
drama that's all it is
redditors who don't post but watch memes
be like fifty three thousand votes okay
I mean whatever floats your boat Jesus
Christ people who believe they can turn
straight men into gaga people who
actually have that kind of power
got'em since when is it me or is this
subreddit super savage lately like let's
get it like we don't care cuz we have
the 50 million club merch like we don't
care what other people think and other
people's feelings we don't have empathy
alright it isn't mumbo Jumbo's fault
YouTube is awful this card was May
as a better Skype it's time for a
battery and that's a fact
damn is it me or is something super
Savage d rehire Papa Gloria for Pugh
news it's not gonna happen
stop crying she's dead that's right she
had no money to pay for her hospital
bills and she passed away last September
and you did nothing much I bet you feel
yeah here it is again
what 24-hour challenge should I do next
why don't you ask mr. bass like
obviously this is blatantly ripping off
but at the same time there's always a
thin line between these things that I
think a lot of people look way too much
into and if I play the same game of
someone else when the little goddamn
game came out that day people still say
oh you're a copy I don't want to promote
that sort of toxic behavior okay I want
everyone to be free and make whatever
video they want but Morris is copying
mr. face and let that word echo
throughout the month end of YouTube
Thank You Felix for both the videos that
you made about the situation meant a lot
that you saw what was going on and the
advice in your second video was
incredibly helpful and appreciated love
you oh man
ah yeah here we go again I'm surprised
to acknowledge the second video because
it was very critical of him I mean props
for that can't tell if genuinely nice or
spineless you definitely watch Pierce
video but apologies very nice but he
didn't reference the mom line which I
thought was good this generation we live
in is disgusting from the beauty
community drama this week two people
take okay so Jake Paul addresses that
people call out on his anti-bullying
video where's the good where's the fun
where's the love too many negative souls
did you read a Bible or something you
wrote diss tracks on your brother abuse
whamon on camera marketed gambling to
kids but now you're spreading love and
positivity shut the Frick up your
blithering ape god damn has this sub
ready got super savage Chad will bring
out the big guns when it's nice
well played hey Chad wouldn't be epic if
I went on cold ones I know I don't do
podcasts but that could be epic cringe
Tuesday material yeah I don't feel so
good mr. Starr I feel like this is setup
though it has to be set up this is fake
when I tell my dad I lost my virginity
what he expects I broke my balls what I
tell him I broke my a ten out of ten
well played guys tech companies when
they changed the Gotham hoji to a water
gun well boys we did it
violence is no more we cancel violence
hashtag violence escapes from everyone
we made a profound positive impact today
and we took a stance against violence
everywhere no one pickets raffle tickets
hey I'm working on it I'm trying to work
out the camera stuff I'm still trying to
figure it out basically all the merch
money will go into trying to figure out
the camera stuff that's right meanwhile
in universe 69 69 I broke my bra Oh
rest in peace
Epps in the chat boys I broke from
abouth hey I remember touching your
balls thank you ball doctor I'm glad you
remember it would make me feel worse if
I went through that traumatic experience
and then you don't even remember it it
was like the one time I kissed a guy for
the first time he remembers nothing I'm
scarred for life not fair another story
time perhaps Tati may not have monetize
her video but she sure is monetizing
mine Tati this video was monetized she
probably made like 200 grand just from
that revenue let's not even get into the
beauty product how can someone be so
lucrative to promote a product that is
supposed to enhance your beauty me
drawing baby pie from memory
yes it's beautiful um thank you for
drawing the nose entering my face that's
very beautiful
I thank you so much if Jack Paul's point
is that you have to be publicly
humiliated to learn then why the Frick
are you the same Jake I added the Frick
there for extra savagery get I wonder
because a lot of people's problem with
Jake criticizing bullying is like where
you're the wrong person to do that
you've done all this bad thing but just
because you've done some bad things does
that mean you're not allowed to
criticize other bad things it seems a
little bit stupid as well but at the
same time he did it so poorly and and I
think trying to pretend like you're
above everyone else at least it seemed
that way in the video I think that's the
issue I don't think it's like Jake can't
criticize these things like it was
insinuated in the first week my point is
I don't have as big of a problem with
Jake Pallas I think people think I have
it's just that I don't where he gets
these ideas when you're kids gets
hepatitis B instead of hepatitis A plus
this is so sad I don't even get the joke
watching an eight minute apology video
watching peers review it for 16 minute I
feel like it's a good testimony if I
managed to make the most painful video
to watch them all time actually
watchable I'll take it papi Gloria after
getting fired this is so sad youtuber
makes bad apology video pues fix it time
it's fixing time you know one of these
days it's gonna bite me in the ass for
being critical of apology videos other
people are just gonna break down minor B
like what I really think he should have
done you will never happen my apologies
are impeccable flawless and perfect yes
look boots block way better angle wave
ever to camera quality thank you so much
early brofist haha that is so cute Oh
another little baby the hell is it my
little brother's born yesterday and I
made him a PewDiePie hat sorry it's not
a meme just start Felix might see that's
so cute
congratulations to your
a little brother baby and the bulbasaur
thing who would win content copying
child and his mum or one cashy boy leave
the comments down in the description and
I'll make sure to pass on the message
directly to YouTube top guys my mom
typing P on Google Tran planet mind me
Wow this is said this is the subreddit
now I really like where this is gone
petition for Felix diet the HOS mean
with you there I am it happen everyone
that's great when Mary Hamm says the
line now I'm not supposed to give my
opinion but how dare you stand where she
stood wanted Mary Hamm wanted for
killing me review having Papa Gloria
fired Mary Hamm don't give up your tube
drama Perry Park in about you to drum
you're welcome guys I like to see it is
doing the job that no one really wants
to do and wasting your time with
pointless information that you could
well enough live without but at least I
summarized it nicely for you just a
nine-year-old cop showing off his
PewDiePie cheap fuel shaker very epic
one of you can fight crime with it you
could probably watch someone with this
not saying that you should thank you for
being not you the best news host can't
marry him now why is everyone hating on
Mary Ann all she did was kill me review
killed Papa Gloria and she likes ham
there's nothing wrong with that evil
versions of youtubers guys it's over
Mary Ann just cancer okay so this is
what I look like with a snapchat filter
I always wondered petitioned for mister
be used to play 20 million trees 420
million subscribers special and
single-handedly saved the earth and then
if mr. base plans a lot of trees that
morgues have to do it as well causing
more trees to be planted possibly saving
the world
let's save the world with some memes
baby that's it for me this week of
check out merch thanks for all the epic
memes but thanks for all the epic laughs
and I'm so sorry about Papa Gloria dying
I sucks
what you never played super simulator
you know it's fun right I'm not supposed
to give my opinion but give it a try and
then you can tell me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay I'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]